how attractive do you think
potential general managers slash head
coaches will actually not slash head
coaches hopefully they don't make that
mistake again and give somebody both
general manager and head coach authority
but but people that run the organization
how attractive do you think they'll find
this job
so there's there's kind of two answers
here right and one of them has to do
with that
slash whatever element that you're just
referencing and we can get into that in
a second but the big picture answer is
that it's an attractive job because
they're all attractive jobs i know
there's some nitpicking going on about
you know the dolphins have their first
and second round pick and the roster
has some talent but hasn't performed up
to expectations in a while but you know
what they have a franchise quarterback
which is not only one of the hardest
things to figure out in football it's
one of the hardest things to figure out
in all of sports if you have desean
watson
it's an attractive job
if it is an nfl head coaching job by the
way it's an attractive job i think we
tend to do this a little bit where we
talk about
you know are there going to be
candidates lining up who want to do this
we did this with the browns a few years
ago of course there are going to be
because there's only 32 of them so i
think to an extent they're all
good jobs right like there's a lot of
guys who want to be able because it's
employment
right
exactly a lot of people right now just
want a good job right yeah on top of
that though if you have watson
a lot of people are going to want the
chance to
rebuild that
and michael that can't be overstated
michael that can't be overstated like
how often does a job come available
because typically these jobs i mean bill
o'brien what was he 52 and 48 won a
division a handful of times
like he completely
screwed up when it came to his
transactions
but typically when jobs become available
job one is to find a quarterback how
many times the 25 year old superstar
who's under contract for the next five
years that job not only is this an
attractive job it is the job like i
don't care how many first or second
rounds you don't have you ain't got to
go look for a quarterback anytime soon
right michael
yeah that that's a that's a huge uh
that's a huge plus for that next coach
and i got to tell you this uh nora and
michael smith you want to talk about a
dream situation
and noah i know you know about this you
gotta you gotta give us a little more
insight on it
the the dream is you start a job at at a
pretty good position let's say like a
mid-level position
and you grow and you and you're running
the organization
like this whole jack easter bee thing
trips me out like
jack easterby
in new england was the team chaplain
hey he was he was telling the team the
beatitudes just like a couple years ago
and now he's running the houston texans
how did this happen norah this is an
unbelievable story legendary story of
jack used to be
it's incredibly strange right and i
should say right off the top i've never
heard a person in new england say
one bad word about jackie easter be the
players that universally
adore him felt that he really helped
them
sort of go through the the stress and
all the work that it takes to go through
a football season and was a confidant
and someone they really respected and
admired and loved working with but it is
a strange career arc
and one thing that i've always found
interesting and wondered about was how
easter bee has balanced his role
certainly in new england and i imagine
he
has
similar responsibilities or at least did
in houston in terms of connecting with
players and being there as someone that
they could talk to
how you balance the things that you
might learn about someone in those
offensively privileged conversations as
someone who's supposed to be making
personnel decisions
at the same time that always seemed a
little bit in conflict to me because
at the end of the day
you don't want to be learning things
that a player might think
they can trust you with and then
spinning them off into
oh well that's in the back of my mind
when i'm thinking about who to cut or
what kind of contract to give out and so
not only is his rise just incredibly
meteoric and
unprecedented i can't think of a similar
situation
in the nfl or really any other sport but
it's a little bit
strange to me just given the types of
roles that he's filled in the past
being the this is away from the
competitive side of what we do here
roles and then very much getting into
personnel decisions how we gonna win
games all of that stuff so
while we just talked about why i think
that's a great job and really all of
these are great jobs
that's one question that if i were
a texans head coach candidate i would be
really curious what exactly is this
structure like
how does this how does this work because
i don't understand it and i was around
the guy in new england for years and i
just i think people
sort of across the league feel that way
like what is going on here so that would
be if i were interviewing for that job
that would be my first question
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports